last one what I want you to picture is
that R and s stay put in fact that's why
I've labeled them RN s over there but I
want you to picture taking P plus Q and
kind of dragging it drag and queue up
the top here so it changes from being a
secant to our keeper tangent okay now
there's a very similar relationship
across here I'm trying to draw this
parallel for you how are we going to
prove the relationship well let's
construct the symmetry groups where are
they I'm going to join up the same pair
of chords I had before right so I'm
going to run up this one over here and
then this one over here okay excuse me
now if you have a look at this because
it's so similar to this diagram it's
just the secret decided to attach it
just like we did in calculus you can
pretty much proceed in much the same way
see this guy over here is still going to
be common between the two triangles you
trying to prove to be similar okay but
what's interesting is you no longer have
a cyclic quadrilateral do you so you
can't take advantage that the exterior
angles like an quad blob of Arc because
you don't have a cycle chord instead if
you look at where those angles are look
where the eggs are we're continuing that
this guy should be equal to this one
down here the bottom smelled a cyclic
quad so what do you go to say the angle
in the alternate segment which we just
looked up this morning is this guy could
look tangent quarter contact right and
over here you've got the big the big
alternate segment over here okay so for
a different reason it's still the same
okay one last time now that you've
established that they are similar and
you can go ahead you can formally prove
it what are the sides that relate to
what well let's have a look here wait so
I said again
ah have a look which are the two
triangles I'm thinking of you know
however here I had a small one and a big
one which overlap right well I have
another small wonder not a big one but
also overlap do you see them this guy up
here in the corner and then the whole
triangle I'm actually not interested in
this triangle this triangle in here is
no good to me okay sorry
my diagram is not perfect okay so to
help you out here right I'm actually
rather than the others because this is
the most confusing I am actually going
to label some points so let's call this
a B C and D okay one of the things
that's nice about that is that now if
for example I drew out four similar
triangles separately for example that
have a look at a BD it looks like this a
b d there's a BD and i'm continuing that
it's similar to the big one ABC do you
see that so i'm going to draw that
separately when train was overlap it's
tricky right so i'm going to draw out
the big one it looks like this this is
the way it's facing a b c angles down
there egg was up there okay so if I were
to state the similarity relationship
here right say for example a triangle
abd is similar to what's the
corresponding order for the other ones
what what angle corresponds to a here
it's still a again isn't it and then
here just be careful abd here goes dot
double and then the unlabeled angle so
therefore here I've got to go dot double
and then the unlabeled angle so it's ACB
does that make sense and again the
reason why we do this is because even
though it's a bit of work to think about
it it seems you work later when you're
doing this part you don't really even
have to think about it because watch
this just look at the order of the
letters and then course match up the
order of letters so for example a B in
the small triangle forget about the
diagrams for a second if this lettering
order is
right then what side does a B in this
triangle correspond to AC you see it's
the first two first two yeah so a B on
AC is going to be equal to what's the
other intercept that we've got over here
C is small an ad a/d have a look again
at these guys just don't forget about
the diagram you've gone out the diagram
now you've got these in order a de
corresponds to AA that's interesting
we've already got this side but it
belongs in both triangles because of the
way that they overlap okay so there's
the ratio relationship so now I can say
a B squared equals AC times ad and now
if I replace out with the original
letters that I began begin with a B
squared is T squared what's the price
over here if you put in alphabetical
order Alex Wyllie another man because
it's the same thing it's the same secret
I haven't moved it anywhere and so it's
the same intercept on that ticket okay
now you're not going to like this but I
promise I've made it as good as I can
grab your sheet out with all your
properties on it this one is the big one
this is the biggest and hardest but I
hope if I write it out for you the right
way and you can fill it in over here as
well it actually will be doable for you
okay let's fill it in on here let's fill
it in on here and then I'm going to
point you to the fact that I actually
encourage you to write a slightly
different way that I think will help
your memory because unlike the smaller
the reference sheet those circle
properties on the reference sheet okay
so here's what we going to fill in the
first thing it says there are three
blanks and it corresponds to this guy
the first three blanks correspond to
this guy right it's something that's
squared do you notice that something
that's squared so the first word in 14
is the square
what's is the square of okay now it the
way I taught it it is the square of the
edge however this tangent could very
likely just go on forever right so T
that interval is not the whole tangent
it is in fact and intercept order the
cages does that make sense so I'm trying
to say look I just want that portion
okay so I'm going to say the square of
the intercepts the Internet's on what on
the teja very good so that's the
left-hand side of the equation
that's in words what T squared means
okay
what's it equal to yeah you're starting
to get it right and this is this you see
why they all have to learn together
right over on the right-hand side
because you dealt with the left-hand
side now you don't have a square over
here you have a product it's something
times something else so you'd say the
square of the intercept on that agent
equals the product worked is what well
there was one intercept of a tangent but
the secret has more than one intercepted
that's a few so you'd say the product is
intercept new rule and we're not to
remount of tangent anymore we're done
with the tangent so now we're talking
about that secant now you see why I said
to you this is the worst one but it also
has a nice sort of it's almost for this
poetic sort of rhythm to it right
because look the first part of it is
that there's a square in it is a product
that you see that a square is just a
particular kind of product right then
you've got these different events in
those intercepts so you see they're
parallel to each other and then lastly
the two shapes that you actually compare
you a tangent and secant right so I in
fact even though you can probably fit on
one line as I have done on the printed
page whenever I write this property in
an actual proof I write it in two lines
like this so I can go one two three one
two three and I know I haven't missed
anything
okay
that way you're really only remembering
six words to lots of three as opposed to
however many words that actually is okay
so I'm showing them to you all together
because they all marry up to similar
triangles okay any questions appetizers
I already gave you the exercise that
relates needs you probably not onto that
which is fine but you've got time to do
that
I am also lastly as I remember I said to
you as you practice you should I
encourage you now that the topic is
inverted commas finished I encourage you
as we move on to the other topics and
just plug away one at a time I'm also
going to give you some HSC questions on
circle geometries there's words so you
can just you know make sure regularly
like if you do even two or three a week
I think that's enough to just keep you a
bit little bit up and you'll learn the
property it's a lot better that way okay
thanks oh yeah sorry
great question to finish this sheet out
you only have one more round at the
bottom sixteen draw this for me we if
you draw some intersecting circles right
not sorry here intersecting so they
overlap so in two circles overlap this
is the last property there when two
circles overlap there's a single cord
that both circles share can you see the
cord see the cord it's between the two
points of intersection so here and here
so because they share this cord we call
it a common chord so when two circles
overlap their common cord
have a look what's the way the sentence
fish is it's something to the interval
between their centers well let's draw an
interval here's one where you get value
here's the other what does it look like
the relationship is a look perpendicular
right it is actually very easy to prove
but that's the property
so it's the last one again to do with
centers I comes up very rarely but it's
kind of cool just to see it and know
that it's true they're full words would
be when two circles overlap their common
chord is perpendicular okay join you
prove it for you it's just really easy
watch this
see that
what else do I did okay I've got um this
one here you don't you don't know that
it bisects yet what you do know is
you've got this so tell me what kind of
shape that is the quadrilateral it's not
quite a rhombus I mean my big I've got a
bigger circle it's a kite right well All
Quiet is a very unusual unused property
because we don't use kites very much all
clients have diagonals that are they buy
set as sorry- well one of them bisects
right but they're always perpendicular
always perpendicular and now you know
it's perpendicular now you know that
this guy is equal to this guy and they
just have a bot load of power and
triangles so they go